en France au Parti socialiste deux jours
après les résultats du référendum qui
ont entériné une large victoire du OUI à
la Constitution européenne on se
demandait quel serait l'attitude de des
partisans du nom allait-il rentrer dans
le rang et faire campagne pour le oui et
bien on a la réponse aujourd'hui de l'un
d'entre eux Jean-Luc Mélenchon il votera
non au référendum et fera campagne pour
le nom
le nom socialiste existe on ne raille
pas d'un trait de plume on ne peut pas
le faire disparaître en agitant le
règlement intérieur du parti un peu
trans il y a des meetings pour le nom
des meetings pour le oui avec des
socialistes pour les meetings pour le
nom s'il y a des socialistes dedans je
vous garantis que ça sera moins choquant
que de voir des socialistes dans des
meetings pour lui avec des gens de
droite parce que de toute façon il y
avait des militants socialistes et de
très haut niveau qui avait annoncé qu'il
participerait à des manifestations et à
des organisations politiques avant même
le vote des militants donc je ne pense
pas que beaucoup se risquent à me faire
la leçon car je serai obligé de leur
rappeler leur propre turpitude alors